hello everyone Hans Hawking Hecht was a
brilliant German Grandmaster and had he
continued pursuing chess he would
probably achieve much more but he had to
give up chess you know and get a real
job to support his family and this isn't
the first game on I'm showing play by
Hans Joaquim Hecht I already showed his
game against nickel towel where it all
had that brilliant Queen sacrifice and
the Miguel night night off gave to Lucas
for his brilliant move but that game he
lost to Michael towel terribly and well
this game is to show that Hans wasn't
without skill himself and it was a
suggestion from a subscriber so let's
see this game hannes is white and he's
played playing against the the English
Grandmaster Raymond Keaney he's actually
the first grandma the first Englishman
to ever achieve a grandmaster norm and
the second Englishman to ever achieved
the Grandmaster title so we have a four
by hunts and see six by Raymond the car
come defense d4 d5 Knight to c3 D
captures on e4 knife captures on e4 and
Knight to d7 and Hans goes for Bishop to
c4 if you're pulling against you know
some friends in a bar or against some
some weaker players you can always try
the Queen e2 the sneaky idea and after
your opponent responds with Knight to f6
go for Knight to d6 checkmate but if
you're playing a serious game you can
always go for a hunt since Bishop to c4
idea we have 90 G to f6 Knight to g5 e
six guarding f7 and now Queen to e2 and
already hunts is preparing some nasty
ideas as well for example if Raymond
isn't careful and plays a move like h6
he immediately gets Knight captures on
f7 and after King captures on f7 Queen
captures on e6 with check King to g6
Bishop to d3
Oh King to h5 and Queen to h3 with
checkmate
so black has to be careful we have Queen
e2 and he goes night to b6 now adding
protection to the e6 pawn from this
bishop and also attacking the bishop on
c4 Bishop f2 b3
h6 kicking the knight Knight to f3 and
c5 and
perfectly fine here D captures on c5
Bishop captures on c5 and Knights the e5
is played
Raymond castles and we have Knight G to
f3 Knight B to D 5 a3 a5 not allowing B
for Hans castles and we have b6
preparing to develop the light square
Bishop c4 kicking the knight from
Central Square 9th day 7 rook to d1
developing the rock and well threatening
Bishop to h7 checked winning the Queen
so Queen to e8 is played Bishop to d2 a4
and Bishop to c3 and you can see that
with every move Hunt's pieces are
looking more and more harmonious Knight
to a5 is played and well this is a this
is an excellent square for the knight
and he's saying to Hunt's well you can
give up your light square Bishop for my
knight I don't mind but you're given up
the bishop pair or I'm provoking you to
push g4 but Hans doesn't mind being
provoked and he goes for it g4 would a
temple Knight goes to d6 and now g5 h
captures and g5 Knight captures and g5
and Bishop to b7 we have a bishop to see
to preparing radius like Queen to d3 g6
stopping ideas like that and we have a
brilliant move here by Hans Hawking
Hecht he plays Knight to d7 and well
this actually this is actually a very
very complicated move as well what's the
idea the idea is that Ramon's the knight
on f6 is now attacked with this Bishop
on c3 and with the night and d7 and you
can capture this night with the night
from f6 if you play Knight captures on
d7 Hunt's idea is Queen to h5 and like
can resign here there is no defense
against Queen to h7 checkmate or Queen
to h8 to checkmate and if you capture
the Queen with G captures on h5 you get
Bishop to h7 checkmate so after Knight
to d7 if you donate is threatening also
to capture on f6 remin played Queen
captures on these
seven in here we have Bishop captures on
f6 Queen to c6 and now black is
threatening Queen to h1 or Queen - G -
checkmate
and what was Hunt's idea here
well his idea was rocked the d5 stopping
checkmate and offering a whole rook here
and grabbing the rook isn't actually the
best move here but as it doesn't seem
like White has anything here Raymond
decided to capture this rook he captures
on d5 was played and now the idea Queen
to h5 and well the idea is pretty much
the same as a couple of months ago you
can't really capture the Queen
immediately but Raymond has an
intermezzo here Bishop captures an f2
would check King captures an f2 and now
Knight to e4 check and Knight captures
and now G captures a queen on h5 and now
there is no more Bishop to h7 checkmate
but there is another one rook to g1 with
check King has to go to h7 and here a
beautiful finisher night to c5 opening
up a discovered check from the bishop
and c2 and in this position the English
Grandmaster Raymond Keeney resigned the
game as the King has only one square he
can go King to h6 and then Bishop to g7
and this is checkmate so yes a beautiful
game by Hans [ __ ] Hecht the German
Grand Master and and if you want you can
also check out his game against McHale
towel on my channel as usual you can
check to my previous games here in my
previous videos and I would like to
thank Tony moored guitar Raja Chaudhary
and the pole Herald for a contribution
to my channel I really appreciate it
thank you a lot and yeah I think you all
for watching and I will see you soon